[Applause]
i haven't seen these you like them i
like the those are the uh mike nesmith
monkeys what 1968
they're kind of the the redneck sort of
cletus
zeke kind of vibe do you like them i
think they're kind of cool i think those
look good yeah
it works yeah see everyone i know isn't
i not many people i know are into them
really yeah yeah no i uh i i think they
look they think they work you think so
they've come back around yeah people are
into that i brought a pair for you
actually
seriously yeah i did oh great here we go
there you go
oh wait they're actually match my uh
hair coloring i think the people in the
back made them
to shape your oh look at this they
actually stick on
this is so thoughtful of you try it out
this is so cool chicks dig it man
i so need the help here we go oh
assuming i'm doing this right is it
right there
it's upside down oh are you sure yeah i
think it goes on the other side
oh god i guess the egg could work as a
stash too actually like that
huh yeah there you go then on this side
over here
oh i'm president james buchanan
the louisiana purchase was the biggest
mistake of your administration sir
no you do feel like fighting a duel when
you wear these these are great we should
go for it
you know i had i had sideburns on the
show not like this but i had sideburns
on the show like a year and a half ago
right and some critic wrote this review
and he said yeah i kind of like the show
but kona looks like a riverboat gambler
the next day shaved them off maybe i
should i'll lose them then if it's not a
good idea
see to me it's like it's the elvis rock
trip of course it's great
yeah yeah it's very cool let's talk
about what you did last night because
that's very unusual you worked
the cash register the tower records at
tower records as like a promotional
thing which i had done 10 years ago you
did it for
10 years ago you did it to make money to
make a living to try to make money
right and was that was that cool did it
work out last night yeah
it was pretty fun same supervisor that i
had when i was working in dc 10 years
ago
and you know what i showed up five
minutes late i hadn't seen this guy in
10 years
and i said tim he goes you're late
like oh my god okay you didn't say i'm a
rock star now
and have some people beat him up of
course i had my security beat the hell
out of it
absolutely what kind of when you really
worked at tower records what kinds of
things would you do to just pass the
time and have fun
[Laughter]
i'm kidding
your actions disgust me sir
no uh what would we do oh well you know
what we used to do wait a minute i'm
just looking i look like general zeus
i'm realizing from planet of the apes
you know that's
interchangeable eight must not kill
eight you can do like mr potato head
and kind of do oh there you go that or
maybe
that
see i look like i've been in an
explosion you look like you're an oasis
actually
anyway i'm william gallagher yeah we
used to we used to take the little
security strips
that you put on cds and put them in the
pulse magazines
which are free so that
old women children oh
pulse magazine and then kind of stepped
through the yay ladies
security guy they start
pounding on an old lady wow
[Laughter]
you were a nice guy we have to talk
about this video for a second learn to
fly because it's kind of interesting
look let's look at some stills here from
the video you're all over this place
this is you of course
that's me i think looking very nice
let's keep moving here
there you are that's me and taylor are
drummers right behind me
uh-huh that must have felt nice and here
i think this is old
here you are as dorothy i think this is
very nice
and they put and what they put braces on
you for that is that right yes i've
always wanted braces
you haven't said one truthful thing when
i was a kid i wanted braces
i wanted glasses i wanted to accessorize
head gear the whole nine
i'm sure but i hope i get horrible acne
please
why can't i have it i did want braces so
badly though and so that was a fantasy
come true and i'm really bummed they
didn't show the whole outfit it was
waist up
i had this cute little blue denim skirt
with white stockings and these huge
fluffy like
rave boots you're frightening us now
what was this move right here what are
you going going to a hoedown
exactly uh that's why i grew the burns
well there is uh
there is nothing left to lose is in
stores now
and uh you know what i've wanted to have
you come on the show for quite a while
now it's very cool to have you here
you know what this is the first time
i've ever gone on to a talk show just to
talk
just to be a guest so i have very funny
i have to say hi to my band
all right guys okay great sorry that i'm
the lead singer but
nicely done dave grohl thanks for coming
today